Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right, what's going on guys. This is Rob and we are covering, uh,
the first issue of soar now. Um.
I'm not really sure what direction this is all going to go in.
And the reality is there's so much happening in X or not really even actually
swords in Dawn of X already. Um,
this might be one of the stories that we do where we only really cover it in
volumes, right?
So we'll cover this first issue and then we won't really cover it again until we
pick up with when,
until it concludes with the first arc and then we'll cover all the rest of it,
you know, and kind of call it like a conclusion or part two, whatever it is.
But I do think it's important to establish that this is here because what this
is doing is it's moving the whole idea of Precoa and the mutant population
beyond earth and focusing more on the stars. Now,
the funny thing about this is that this is written by Al Ewing and in recent
years, Al Ewing has kind of become the new Dan Adams, right?
Those guys who don't know what that means for years leading up to like 2006.
When I say years, I mean like decades, Marvel's whole, uh,
I guess space escapades, their space opera was usually sort of, uh,
hit by different people here and there, but it was never really cohesive. Right?
So you go back and you read the old Jim Starlin warlock stories,
or the old Jim Starlin Thanos, silver surfer stories.
Then you see a lot of space, very escapades there.
You had stories involving Wendell Vaughn as quasar. You had stories involving,
uh, captain Marvel himself, right. Marvel of the Creek,
but you didn't really have any kind of cohesiveness there. You had story arcs,
right?
So you had like infinity war or infinity gauntlet or the infinity crusade or
something like that. But in 2006,
Dan admin basically took the entirety of everything going on in space and Marvel
and consolidated all of it down into a story called annihilation and
annihilation led into an Eilish and conquest, which led into this great, big,
huge expansion of all the spacefaring operas that Marvel had going on.
So that's why you saw stories like rise and fall of the [inaudible] empire,
where Vulcan,
who was the third summer's brother in Omega level mutant left earth and took
over the Shar empire.
Then you had the war of Kings realm of Kings different things like that.
But Al Ewing in a lot of ways seems to be the guy that Marvel turns to for
writing things that have to do with space.
But what also want to do here is offer a bit of exposition in terms of sword.
So sword is this organization that was created by Josh Weeden back in
astonishing.
X-Men really just Wieden and John Cassidy back with astonishing X-Men and the
return of Colossus,
but the whole purpose behind this is that if shield monitors threats on earth,
then sword monitors threats to space.
And so it basically stands for the Sinti of world observation and response
directorate. And the,
the whole purpose is to just monitor threats that are out there that are
potential threats to earth, but also stand as a kind of kind of ambassador,
right? So if there were a great, big,
huge coming together of all the different alien races that exist out there in
Marvel comics, then Abigail brand would represent the solar system, right?
So you'd have like a representative for the CR and a representative for the
Cree. And the representative for the scrolls are really the Korean,
the scrolls now because they've, they've joined forces,
but all the different alien races that are out there and then Abigail brand
would represent humanity in the salt system, right in the Milky way. Galaxy, um,
the idea behind sword is that for a long time, it was, I mean, it was,
it had some okay moments here and there, but during the incursions,
right during Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and new Avengers,
and in the aftermath of that,
that sword was effectively rebranded into what became the alpha flight
directorate or off of Fred protocol program or whatever you want to call it
with. Carol Danvers went in show.
This was an attempt by Marvel to elevate the popularity of Carol Danvers.
It didn't really work. The story just really wasn't that great.
And it just really wasn't written all that well.
And so that kind of lasted until the empire event that we recently saw to
include that we didn't finish because it sucked.
But what you ended up getting is this segment whereby Abigail brand basically
quit the alpha flight program.
And the reason why is because alpha flight was a reactionary organization,
they would wait until a threat got there.
And then they would react that in the fact that the superheroes would never give
any information to the alpha flight program because sword success came in.
The fact that sword could happen to all the information available to shield and
like the NSA and the FBI and the CIA,
and even the various other superhero groups that would all funnel information to
sword to basically say, Hey, look, uh, like I summoned Galactus,
he's going to be stopping by, right. So he's not going to be a threat, just FYI,
don't shoot him with your big lasers. Otherwise you'll kill us off.
That was kind of what,
like the fantastic four would do or something along those lines. Um,
and so because of that, well, what were your,
what did basically have here is we don't really know the current state of the
alpha flight program. It seems to still exist.
I wouldn't be surprised if Manuel does kind of Whitely phases it out.
Like it's just never really seen or heard from again, I mean,
we have referenced here, right?
So it seems to exist only in so far as Abigail brand quit.
But if the alpha flight program still exists, then sword has become,
I'm an extension of the mutant population because Abigail brand is a mutant that
has the ability to speak and understand any language similar to cipher,
but it's kind of like an alien language,
just not every language in existence ever.
Then what this basically means is that sword operates on behalf of Precoa.
And that's why this opens up with Magneto showing up here,
because soar now operating as an extension of Precoa kind of falls under the
purview of Coca-Cola.
And that's why Abigail brand being here she's being returned as the leader of
sword. Right?
Because she was originally the leader when the group was first introduced by
Josh Sweden. And she's really was really kind of a return to familiarity, right?
She's white back where she belongs more or less now for cables part in the
aftermath of the 10 of swords event,
he's actually been elevated to the chief of security for sword.
But the funny thing about this is that a lot of people, and even with Magneto,
a lot of people don't really fully grasp the power of Magneto.
And it's one of these things where whenever you see him use his abilities,
you don't usually see him do it unlike a broad scale, right?
You don't really see him do like some Breezy's super ridiculous.
It's usually something like smaller nuanced stories,
maybe some kind of interesting set of circumstances,
but cable's mind is totally blown when,
while he's talking to Magneto and Magneto is having this conversation and
talking about the whole basis behind like the sword peak is what is called the
base operations for sword. It's called the peak Wallace called that, you know,
while, while there we're having this discussion and all that kind of stuff,
Magneto basically takes this 10,000 tons space station and changes it and like
moves it and puts it in a place more in line with worker Cola believes it should
be, he just doing it as an arbitrary thing. Well,
he's literally doing multiple things at the same time, right?
So like where you may find yourself something where like you aimlessly play with
something in your hands, right. Or you might tap a pencil while you talk,
imagine a sort of tapping that pencil, having a conversation.
And then thinking about a few things at the same time,
you're moving a 10,000 times space station across space.
That's basically Magneto. Now we have seen him do crazy things like that, right?
Like we've seen him pull like a bullet from sheer space, right.
Just yank it towards earth or something along those lines.
I think Katie pride was inside. I don't remember off the top of my head.
We've seen some crazy demonstrations of his power and this is yet another one.
Right. It's just been a while since we've seen that.
But that's the thing like Magneto's power is extreme, right? It's,
it's crazy how powerful he is.
And that's why I've always advocated for the idea that while I don't know if
it's explicitly been stated,
I don't remember if Jonathan Hickman modified this when he listed the new Omega
level mutants in Marvel comics, but Magneto,
if he's not listed already needs to be one, right. He's just that powerful.
Now from there, Magneto basically gets a tour of where things stand with the,
with the sword space station itself.
And we actually ended up picking up with a guy by the name of a Takeshi Matsuda,
right. To Kashi Matsuda. This guy is old school, right?
So he originally appeared back in the old exterminator comics, um,
really the exterminators, uh, in 19 1888. And he's been around for a long,
long time.
I think as big as his claim to fame really came when he served on generation X.
So like Emma fros own X-Men team back in the day, uh, we're in a process,
started out as a villain and she had her hellions team.
Eventually the hellions were destroyed and she ended up allying herself with
Charles Xavier and then lead generation X as their own personal X-Men team.
Like her own personal new music,
more or less to Kashi is one of these guys where he can basically kind of
control and really manipulate things that are part of a machine.
But the way the model explains this is not true just in technological fashion,
right? So it's not like he's a Tony stark type character that's really empower.
He basically,
anything that works as part of a greater cohesive unit is considered to be part
of a machine, right? So if you had like six mutants,
all of whose powers complemented themselves then to catch,
he could basically use that uses mutant powers and find the most optimal way for
those mutant powers to work in unison. That's kind of how this whole thing,
how this whole thing works. So biotechnology, uh, human technology,
any form of technology he can effectively manipulate.
So its powers are pretty extreme because it goes beyond just like, you know,
I can understand how this robot works and I can reverse engineer iron man's
armor. And it, it moves way beyond that. Right? So if you put him,
I would wager that if you put them in charge of the Avengers or even just the
X-Men right, if, if like the X-Men had to go to war,
they would probably end up hitting up Takeshi and saying, here's our roster.
How would these mutant powers best work together? And he's like, well, I mean,
because you guys are working as kind of a well-oiled machine, so to speak,
then this guy should do this and she should do that and they should do this.
And like these four people should fight together and those six people should
fight together. And that kind of thing. Now we don't know the full depth of it,
the full brunt of it,
Marvel never really bothered to explain the full depths of what the cashier was
capable of. Um, we, we will probably end up seeing that over time, but again,
he's kind of the guy that's sort of helping to keep the space station together.
He kind of works as the control center.
So like the brain of the space station more or less,
but we kind of get this continued bit of a,
of an explanation for this continued bit of a tour with everything going on.
And that's when Abigail brand really kind of hits on the big reason why she left
alpha flight. And the big explanation given here is,
is really kind of what we've already reiterated that with alpha flight,
they never really had the resources to do what they want it to do. Right?
The alpha flight was a publicly available government sanctioned superhero,
or really a, I guess, a space station kind of program,
but they never really had the right resources back in the day.
She'll had a blank paycheck.
They had whatever they needed to do to achieve anything at any point in time.
It's what made the old school. Nick fury such a dangerous Scott,
as he gets happen to any database, he had all the money in the world.
Nobody would ever really say no to him. And so because of that,
they could achieve virtually anything sort of had that when Abigail brand was
initially running it when it first popped up, but when it became awful flight,
then suddenly there were just massive limitations on it.
And it couldn't really fulfill its charter.
And so once she's retaken over everything,
he kind of came to this realization that the universe isn't a lot of ways facing
some pretty dire threats. She doesn't go as far as to say it directly,
but basically Nola's heading towards earth.
So we know that like sword number one takes place before the events of King and
block. There's like various, you know,
alien races out there that are warring against each other that could destabilize
galactic peace. So while sword isn't necessarily the universe's police force,
the purpose of sword is to monitor threats out there and to try to bring those
threats to an end if for no other reason than to keep earth protected. Right?
So like what we saw with the original priests for war that the Korean,
the Sprole went to war against one another.
And while they were races that had been warring for millions of years and had
virtually nothing to do with earth outside of the CRE creating Inhumans on
earth, that when the conflict came close enough to earth,
that it actually threatened the earth itself. And so the purpose of,
of sword is to say, look, yes, they're warring empires that are out there.
You'll probably never come here, but it's entirely possible that they could.
And because they could,
we need to get involved in order to kind of bring things to an end.
So they're indirectly kind of responsible in that way.
The next person that we actually end up seeing here is a person by the name of
frenzy and frenzy. If I remember correctly,
frenzy has indestructable skin and super strength,
but she is a character that's really, really, really, really old school.
She's been around for a very long time. Kind of a fun fact.
She was actually working for apocalypse when he first showed up in Marvel comics
and the old X-Factor stories under Walter Louie Simon's son.
So she goes way back, right?
The frenzy is a powerhouse rush is kind of the muscle of the team rush is the
muscle of the, of the six as they call them. That's what we kind of get, right?
Each of these individuals here offers something unique to the, to the,
the peak in such a way to where they can be utilized,
or it can utilize itself at its full capacity.
And all that whole structure information really seems to be done by way of the
efforts of Takeshi, right? Kind of working together and saying, look,
these are the other five people that I need to do.
These particular things that can basically help this thing operate in his peak
capacity.
Now what the sword actually does is not really just monitoring space.
They have a much bigger charter going on and we'll find out what that is here in
a second, because what you end up getting is this,
this kind of group sort of coming together, you know,
in a mission effectively getting ready to take off, right. A mission,
getting ready to happen. And everybody, you know,
traveling to what's called the, uh,
the launch pad or the jump suite where they basically teleport. But,
but we actually get to familiar faces here. Anybody,
any of the guys who've been reading Marvel comics for,
I would say the better part of 20, some odd years,
you're going to see couple of faces here that are old school that you probably
recall. The first one is paper.
And I didn't initially realize that people would come back.
It wasn't until I was in the discord,
talking to you guys for the weekly Q and a that I do every Friday at 6:00 PM
Eastern time shameless plug. Uh, but I was,
I was in the Q and a session talking to you guys, you know,
answering your questions. And one of the guys asked me about sword,
and you said that paper came back. So Pieper is one of the oldest, I mean like,
Oh, G double O G brotherhood of evil mutants guys.
I think he was part of the original brotherhood of evil mutants Magneto,
if not the original in the second iteration. Uh, but he's super old school.
They've been around for a very, very long time. And they've actually,
they've been friends for a very long time. Now, the fact that paper's back,
of course, Magneto gruesome is an old friend, is like, dude,
I had no idea that you were on this. We didn't get back together, man.
Like we need to hang out, we'll grab a beer. And like we'll,
we'll chit chat and talk about all kinds of stuff.
But the funny thing is that Fabian Cortez is left out of all of that.
Now Fabian Cortez was part of the acolytes right back in the 1990s,
when you got X-Men volume two and to kind of relaunch under Chris Claremont,
Jim Lee,
and then eventually Scott Ladelle and a few other people once Jim Lee and Chris
clay Fairmont left.
But the acolytes were like these people who worship at Magneto, right?
Like they basically did almost every,
every single bit of that he could possibly do ask for Fabian courts has had the
ability to augment the powers of other people. Um,
but he was by no means like a major player.
The funny thing about that if I remember correctly,
because sometimes I get the TV show and the comics us switch,
but I believe Fabian port has tried to topple Magneto, but whatever it is,
Magneto doesn't really remember his name. He's like, I remember the ponytail,
but the name escapes me.
So Fabian Cortez was never really that important to him in the first place.
And so it leaves a little bit of room for jealousy.
I doubt we'll actually see that. But at that point,
the mission begins to commence.
And these guys are addressing these wild looking space suits because they're not
traveling out into space.
They're actually breaking the dimensional barrier and they're traveling to three
different locations.
Now these three different locations here are represented by what's called the
far shore. The land of couldn't be shouldn't be and the white house, no,
the white hot room. A lot of you guys already know.
And we'll talk about that here. The far shore in the land of couldn't be,
shouldn't be, those are the,
those are the one's a lot of people probably don't really know much about right.
And a stands to reason because they're very new concepts.
And when I say very new,
like they've been introduced in the last four or five years.
And so nobody's really done anything with them.
Usually when it comes to like abstract ideas like that,
they have to be around for something like 20 years, right.
Nor to actually get a general consensus of what they are because a boatload of
different writers and artists interpret them in different ways.
So the far shore is a concept that explained to us and really given to us during
the old ultimate line of comics, by Al Ewing,
select the Ultimate's with Adam Bashir and black Panther and spectrum and all
those characters, part of all new, all different Marvel. Um,
but we never really got a definitive explanation in terms of what it really is.
The closest explanation that we get comes at the end of the ultimate story.
When we're basically told that if you look at everything,
the universe that exists out there,
every universe has this one version of like eternity or infinity or something
like that.
And free version of the multi-verse has this own version of the multi-verse
eternity, the multi-verse infinity.
And so every time a universe dies and is reborn the version of eternity that
existed when that universe died, basically ceased to exist.
And when the universe is reborn,
a new version of eternity is born in to that new universe.
And so the question becomes if that version of eternity that died,
when the malt, when the universe died is gone, didn't board, his ego,
does he simply cease to exist? And for, for the most part,
I think it's just an easier explanation to say that, right,
that version of eternity, ceases to exist and like a new one takes his place.
But the answer that was given to us by our viewing is they go to the far shore.
So like when the multi-verse die during the events of secret Wars and was reborn
again, uh, that we basically ended up getting like all those versions of oils,
versions of the cosmic entity. So like eternity, infinity, master order,
Lord chaos, the in-betweener that all those cosmic entities basically dot.
And when the multi-verse was recreated by reading Richard's that for the most
part, they were brought back the way they were before.
So nothing really changed. But if you look at the multi-verse, the way it died,
when like gallon moved into the new, uh, new multi-verse and became Galactus,
right? That trend period, that,
that version of eternity from the previous multi-verse that version of infinity,
all those different cosmic entities from all of those different universes that
were all wiped out. When that multi-verse collapsed,
they all went to the far shore. Now what they do when they're there,
we don't know. Maybe they sit around all day and watch golden girls.
Maybe they play ping pong, who knows? Maybe they watch my videos.
I have no clue. We really don't know what it is that they do. We're never,
but an answer, right. It's just kind of,
it's basically a place where they go when they quote unquote pass on, right.
When they basically die and go on to whatever awaits the next.
And so from there you go into, what's called the land of couldn't be,
shouldn't be now the land of couldn't be, shouldn't be, it's basically, uh,
a kind of dimension or space that represents every conceivable possibility
that has not come to fruition yet. Right?
So let's make this tangible because I know this is kind of wild.
Let's say that you have a plate of cookies sitting next to you.
You have a chocolate chip cookie,
you have a sugar cookie and you have an oatmeal raisin cookie, and Lola,
anybody would eat that. Now the there's a possibility,
all those possibilities exist, right?
There's a possibility that you could eat the chocolate chip cookie.
There's a possibility you could eat the sugar cookie.
And there's a possibility you could eat the oatmeal raisin cookie.
But until you do,
those are only possibilities where there are only options that exist out there.
There's there. They haven't come to fruition yet. And so that's what,
that's what that whole kind of dimensional place answers. Right? If these ideas,
if these possibilities exist, then where do those possibilities come from? Now,
the reality is that this is adding a level of complexity to something that
doesn't need that level of complexity.
We don't need a dimension to represent all the possibilities that could exist in
mobile commerce, right? We can just call that imagination and be done with it,
right? That's all it is. That's all it really needs to be.
But Marvel likes to assign a dimensional spaces and cosmic entities to different
ideologies. For whatever reason, it only makes sense to themselves. And so the,
the land of couldn't be,
shouldn't be represents those three cookies sitting on those plates.
Now let's say for example, that you decide to eat that chocolate chip cookie,
then that becomes a reality, right?
You now live in a universe where you ate that chocolate chip cookie.
There is an alternate reality out there where you ate the oatmeal raisin cookie.
And there's an, an alternate reality where you ate the sugar cookie, right?
Like there's, there are now alternate realities for those,
because with that situation being there,
the very fact that you chose to eat a cookie means now you chose to eat all the
other cookies where you chose to eat. None of them.
I know it's really weird and it's really wild and Metta textual.
And that's why I say not everything that can exist, needs to exist.
Not every idea that somebody comes up with needs to actually be put in comic
books. So if you find yourself a little confused,
just kind of sit on that for a little while and just kind of ponder it,
and then it'll eventually make sense to you after a while. But from there,
they finally managed to make their way into the white hot room, right.
And access something called the Mysterium. Tremendum don't know what that is,
where it's the first time that we saw it at this, this stuff's kind of cool.
It seems a little unnecessary. And that's why I say like, it's,
it's an awesome concept,
but it's really kind of running like just throwing in too much wild stuff too
fast. But again, it could all make sense by the time we get to the next issue,
whatever this is though, this basically kind of seems to be a cosmic, uh,
like an elemental cosmic heart, right? The heart of the white hot room.
Now the white hot room feels, you guys don't know what this is.
This is basically where you have the Phoenix force in its full totality, right?
The full power of the Phoenix force. Now,
just because of person is possessed by the Phoenix force does not mean they can
use the Phoenix force to its full potential that in order for that to happen,
there has to be an almost kind of alignment between the genetic potential of the
person who is, Oh, for the Phoenix force and the Phoenix force itself. Right.
So that's where like Jean Gray is the quote unquote perfect host for the
Phoenix. Someone like I think, uh, I think Emma Frost achieved at four time.
I believe Rachel Summers has. Um,
and I think I know Quentin choir did in an alternate universe. Um,
but basically a person who is who who's able to possess the totality of the
Phoenix powers is what's called the white Phoenix of the crowd, right?
That's basically what they are a person who can achieve and use the Phoenix's
abilities to their full totality,
a person who achieves that level occupies and exists inside the white hot room.
But we never really got a full on explanation beyond that. Right.
That's the old Prince Clermont stuff that was kind of revisited by grant
Morrison during his one on X-Men with here comes tomorrow. But beyond that,
we don't really have a full on explanation there in terms of like,
what all is inside the white hot room.
We're told that it's like kind of surrounded by like a lattice work, you know,
and it's like a place of pure energy,
but what they seem to have done here is taken the heart of the white hot room,
right? This,
this object that can kind of maintain these sort of elemental capacities.
Now what that means and what it does. I have no idea.
I don't know if attaining this makes them all God,
I don't know if it just allows them to tap into a level of power.
Maybe it makes them super smart. We don't really know.
It's one of these things where just because there's an artifact that holds a
ceremonial role does not mean that artifact is going to grant a person,
absolute power indicative of that role. Right?
So this artifact resides in the white hot room.
The only people who can access the white hot room are people who are able to use
the Phoenix force at 100% of its power air ergo,
anybody who has this artifact can possesses the full totality of the Phoenix has
powers. We don't know that we're assuming that,
but we don't actually have an answer for that.
The result is we're just going to kind of have to wait and see what all this
means. But once they attain this artifact and they bring it back,
the only thing that we're really told is like, this is what comes next, right?
Like this is basically what, what comes after all this? What that means.
I have no idea, right. As a great, big, huge mystery. I'm digging it. I like it.
I think it's cool. And I'm excited to see what comes of it. Uh,
our viewing almost never disappoints as a writer.
I don't think I've ever read a bad story that Al Ewing wrote.
So I'm excited to see where this goes, but it is a little wild.
It is a little kooky, but it leaves room for some pretty breezy events,
especially because we're going cosmic in this. Right?
So probably a lot of involvement involving cosmic entities,
different things like that. So with that being said, guys,
putting them in this video to an end, if you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the rod
port. If you guys enjoy this video, make sure you drop a like,
and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].